hello guys I'm Ryan right still at you a
cosplayer here if you guys know what a
cosplayer is you didn't know I didn't
know no I didn't know I was getting
myself into so here's some photos of her
that way is she dresses up like anime
characters video game characters all
anything she really loves she designs
the costumes herself she dresses up in
them and she's also a burlesque dancer
and vlogs on her YouTube channel
BAM promoted you we're good my branded
stuff people were telling us that the
warcraft sneak-peek trailer I can't
believe there's a traitor there's a
sneak peek to a trailer it's a it's a
teaser to a trailer it's like so weird
to me but anyway yeah there's like 15
seconds long she actually likes World of
Warcraft a lot I have not played World
of Warcraft join the Horde become one of
us it's man enjoy the horror for a
second
yeah well oh heroin that's what that's
good that's good yeah I hope you know
that most of our subscribers have a
family with heroin addictions so you
have just offended most of the stuff
they can actually use this as a way to
recover yeah this world of warcraft be a
replacement better than meth you're
right if you're addicted to something
get addicted to something else that's
what they teach you in rehab
alright
oh yeah I don't know if you got chills
good idea I have chills
sell your female so I have to use your
back-end for this what when I get chills
it goes to the net sounds like only
that's not where your heart is whoa I
don't even know World of Warcraft but I
was looking at that 15 second let's
watch it again yeah
those videos is so fast
okay okay listen I want to go first as
someone who's just having a perspective
here from the movie standpoint then I
want to hear your thoughts my video game
inspired yeah thoughts what I like about
it is it's it seems like it's a hybrid
of you know something like Lord of the
Rings but mixed in with a little bit of
cannon fire so it's like that mythical
thing going on everyone loves that [ __ ]
when it's executed right it looks epic
I loved it from the first shot when he
jumps off onto the eagle and I like how
he switches swords in between I've never
seen that done before where you switch a
sword midair that's pretty badass okay
and it's called world of warcraft so you
want a [ __ ] war to take place and man
does it look [ __ ] intense and epic
the visuals look great usually when I
see like giant animals killing someone
I'm like that looks like CGI but it
wasn't distracting to me when I was
watching it I was like this looks
[ __ ] intense yeah and when I gotta
say is usually I watch like these
15-second sneak peeks and I'm like
whatever I'd rather just wait for the
whole trailer that made me go I gotta
see the whole trailer when it comes out
yeah that looks [ __ ] sweet I know
it's only 15 seconds but for someone
who's played the game are there any like
connections or correlations you're
making I don't know if this is for sure
but like I'm pretty sure that's like an
origin story of like what's going on
with like the worlds because you know
like 20 years ago when the first game
came out they had like a storyline it
was humans versus orcs and that's what
I'm seeing in here is there's the humans
who are like all like and beautiful and
their armor and stuff and then you have
the orcs who are actually are just
they're not wearing armor they're like
big guys and there's a huge horde of
them and it looks like it's just gonna
be them versus humans in the game can
you have sex with the orcs no but you
can dance really sexy with those but you
can't actually do like penetration no no
there's people who tried to do videos of
it and it'll it's pretty fun I wish I'd
ship that a lot why don't you ship that
oh that's a saying that us nerdy like
anime fans say it's like I relationship
them I ship them oh I thought you meant
like you ship a hooker like that's how I
say I shouldn't I
oh really yeah what does that mean I get
I get me these I get them from across
the world I don't like to go to
corner of Van Nuys Boulevard I like to
you know I'd like to get hookers on a
ship yeah it's you like a cruise they go
alright yeah so it's relaxing for them
they show up and they might want to do
it Monday no usually yeah or ship calm
alright sounds like horse [ __ ] like so
much I want to talk about about this
okay I'm gonna scroll through cuz like I
have my own input that looks like storm
wind which or maybe it isn't yeah
totally looks like storm wind that's a
city that's inside the game um where
like all the humans cocaine by the way
just saying I said don't do that much
cocaine before we thought I can't help
I'm from New York got some royalty
happening over there so there's the set
design and production design look like
World of Warcraft oh yeah yeah okay you
see like this the sigil right here
that's of the humans yeah the lion the
Alliance yeah well it's not just humans
there's like night elves dwarves you
know it's funny all those categories you
can also get from horse ship calm yep
and then over here you see the orcs
these guys are like beige skin orcs but
later on you see some like green orcs
right there ah some Shrek's mm-hmm some
tracks and this part this part confuses
me like who summons a direwolf to attack
them maybe maybe it's like a hunter who
comes with cousin you know there's like
the different like oh you don't know yes
I'm so there's different classes in the
game and Hunter has a wolf that he like
sends out and attack people would oh my
god he's like seriously because bite his
head off there's no recovering for that
if you guys like slow down this 15
seconds frame by frame there's a lot of
[ __ ] going on right now
they say kind of true to world warcraft
they're famous for having like
obnoxiously large pauldrons
like they're like this big right and
what's up old room it's the thing that
sits on your shoulder to protect you oh
yeah yeah yeah so they scaled the down a
lot but it's still really huge on their
shoulders I should get one to protect
myself against Veronica yeah mm-hmm
because it's an abusive relationship
should
there's a hotline for that she knows the
people at the hotline and they think I'm
the one at fault I can't help you man
you have to help yourself that's what
all my friends they suffer Annika says
when she hits me and right there you
have an order coming down on you with
his axe look at that I'm going down damn
girl with an axe now doesn't work so
we're all wearing axe yes you help
complete it okay we're gonna we're gonna
try to find a way to insert that joke
again later on anyway guys thanks for
tuning in to the channel if you're new
today you can subscribe today and become
a rejected craft get less and less cool
as Stella as a YouTube channel currently
has a big following on Facebook but she
has a YouTube channel now and you should
check it out you got cosplay videos
vlogs and she's gonna be covering more
anime you should check it out subscribe
now and that way you can get more
awesome videos from her and Stella I
like to do shout outs to the fans
Jorge Rodriguez hey Ryan
I would love a shout-out for my channel
final order media thanks man also
wondering if maybe you guys can make
more videos like the 4/20 shout outs for
20 shots is when we got stoned and did
some shout outs were we really stoned
yes we're hitting yes we were baked off
our minds I live in California let's see
what you let's see what you look like
buddy because everything on YouTube it
has nothing to do with your personality
only looks so I want to see what you
look like okay looks like a studious man
he looks like a studious man however and
I'd be getting this vibe alot from a lot
of subscribers and because I said that a
lot of you subs know what I'm about to
say now serial killer mmm
serial killer vibe mmm-hmm it could just
be a cosplay outfit a serial killer most
serial killers are collegiate graduates
yeah and they look like oh they're
friendly and warm and welcoming that's
the manipulative tactic that you freaks
use you're mean Jorge but yeah check out
his channel final order media where it's
so related to everything we shattered
out about him yep sir we're killers are
us it's an organization you could donate
to